der Ballett Choreograph Marco Goecke hat
wenig zimperlich auf einer harsche
Kritik an seinem neuesten Werk reagiert
während der Pause einer Premiere an der
Staatsoper Hannover beschmierte er die
fatskulturkritikerin Wiebke hüster mit
Hundekot im Gesicht die Kritikerin hatte
sein Stück als Verfahren und
unkonzentriert zerpflückt diese Attacke
auf eine Journalistin die verbreitete
sich weltweit wie ein Lauffeuer einige
forderten natürlich sofort den Rücktritt
des Choreografen einige andere zeigten
aber sogar Verständnis der sich Gülke
und Publikum sein Lebenswerk um seine
Tänzer die hart und intensiv gearbeitet
haben sorgte darüber sprechen wir jetzt
hier bei 8:15 Uhr sie sind selbst
Journalist haben Sie Verständnis für
eine so extreme Form des Protest für
eine so extreme Reaktion auf Kritik nein
also darauf habe ich dafür habe ich kein
Verständnis es ist ja ihre Aufgabe der
Kollegin als Theaterkritikerin auch
entsprechend Kritik auch aufzuschreiben
und zu formulieren
ich finde dennoch bei allen
stallvorlagen die dieser Vorgang
natürlich diese ungeheuerlich Vorgang
würde ich sagen schon auch liefert hat
er schon auch einen wahren Kern insofern
dass wir uns bisher gerade schon richtig
im gesagt hatten auch der Frage stellen
müssen wie weit kann Journalisten
eigentlich gehen im Wald dürfen
Journalisten eigentlich gehen jetzt
unabhängig von diesem konkreten Vorfall
aber wenn wir uns auch in den
vergangenen Jahren erlebt im Rahmen der
Corona Debatte ganz ganz stark auch im
dass man schon das Gefühl hatte das oft
sich Journalisten dann vom Schreibtisch
aus irgendwie für die gute Pointe dann
auf Kosten von anderen sich vielleicht
manchmal etwas mehr überlegen sollten
welche Konsequenzen das sind auch für
die einzelne Person haben könnte
wie bewertest du das dass es ist klar
ist jetzt suspendiert zumindest in
Hannover andere halten an dem Fest
glaubst du er wird überhaupt die Chance
haben jemals wieder eine Bühne zu
betreten also Patricia ich habe auch
darüber nachgedacht so was ist Themen
durch den Kopf gegangen der Mann ist 50
Jahre alt als er diese Kacke ich glaube
das kann man so sagen der Dame ins
Gesicht geschmiert hat und ich glaube
dass er eigentlich ein Kunstwerk damit
selber setzen wollte irgendwie eine
eigene Form von Kunst sie haben gesagt
wie weit dürfen Journalisten gehen eine
eigene Form von Kunst etablieren und ich
glaube ein bisschen feiert er sich dafür
natürlich ist das großes Turbo er hat
wahnsinnig viel Kritik aber zwei oder
drei Jahre später mal sehen was die
Leute dann sagen ob sie nicht vielleicht
sagen da war doch ein guter Kniff
dahinter zumindest erinnert man sich
wahrscheinlich in diesen Namen in der
wahrscheinlich negativen aber man
erinnert sich natürlich an diesen Namen
ähm zumindest einige halten an dem Fest
die Stuttgarter Tanz companyi Dance
weiter mit ihm zusammenarbeiten der
Fleischer finden Sie man darf man sollte
vielleicht sogar so eine Attacke auch
verzeihen können
ja das finde ich es ist ja ein Künstler
er ist kritisiert worden er hat sein
ganzes Herzblut reingegeben in das Stück
ich meine abstraktes Theater abstraktes
ballett ist vielleicht jetzt nicht
jedermanns Sache ja
aber ich denke schon dass man ihm es
sind ist auch schon ganz andere Leuten
für ganz andere Sachen verziehen würden
schauen wir
mal Reiher selbst dazu zu sagen hat dann
auch er hat sich geäußert
ich denke dass die die die die Wahl der
Mittel sicherlich nicht super waren
absolut und natürlich ist das
gesellschaftlich auch bestimmt nicht
anerkannt oder respektiert wenn man
solche zu solchen Mitteln greift und ich
bin auch ein Mensch der sowas gar nicht
noch nie gemacht hat
insofern bin ich natürlich auch ein
bisschen erschrocken über mich selber
und das was sicherlich nicht die Mittel
waren sicherlich nicht gut aber wenn man
natürlich in der Öffentlichkeit steht
und
[Musik]
mein Beruf mein Werk mein Geschäft
über Jahre auch durch so jemanden durch
seine
Journalistin beschmutzt sieht und dann
gibt's halt auch immer nur die Antwort
ja das ist der Preis wenn man eine
Person des öffentlichen Lebens ist aber
da bin ich ab einem gewissen Punkt bin
ich da auch anderer Meinung
so wir haben also alle über ihn
gesprochen jetzt haben wir ihn auch hier
in der Runde gehört Herr Schaal haben
sie eine Entschuldigung rausgehört in
aus diesem Sätzen nein ich habe da keine
Entschuldigung rausgehört und ich sag
mal die Auseinandersetzungen auch um
Kunst und Kultur sollten doch im Bereich
des verbalen bleiben also jegliches
beschmieren oder festkleben an an Dingen
und Gegenständen wie wir das ja auch
hier in Auseinandersetzung mit der
klimaprozessbewegung sehen sollte
unterlassen bleiben das wird uns in
unserer Demokratie
es wurde Anzeige erstattet natürlich von
der Journalistin sie sind ja auch
JuristInnen jetzt also ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das natürlich eine
Beleidigung darstellt und da können
schon ich weiß jetzt nicht ob er
Wiederholungstäter ist dazu müsste man
müsste man sich das anschauen das hört
sich ja so an als hätte dass das erste
Mal gemacht insofern denke ich ist er
damit dein Geldstrafe wahrscheinlich
Geldstrafe und das war's auch nicht
unterschätzen das kam jetzt schon raus
so ein bisschen also ist es ja ein
Unterschied ob ich etwas sage das war
okay weil oder ob ich versuche zu
erklären was jemand dazu bringt so ein
Schritt zu gehen vielleicht aus einem
komischen Impuls heraus weil ich mich
frage wer das Tütchen plötzlich hatte
aber das wird noch erklärt
besitzt ein Dackel in der Pause wurde
der offenbar Gassi geführt hat
er das entweder das weiß natürlich
niemand mit Plan in der Tasche oder so
in der Tasche das können wir hier
natürlich nicht klären aber so ist
glaube ich ist glaube ich der Punkt
jetzt oder gesagt hat diese diese
gewisse Machtlosigkeit die glaube ich
ähm unser einer vielleicht gar nicht so
richtig oft nachvollziehen kann weil wir
ja selbst die sind die die Plattformen
haben uns zu artikulieren um uns quasi
auch zu streiten und alles und wenn ich
natürlich jemand bin der wie er
zumindest angedeutet hat jetzt überall
ich kann es nicht beurteilen quasi immer
wieder ein Verlust nach dem anderen über
sich lesen musste und vielleicht ist ihm
da jetzt einfach mal die Schnur doch
gegangen ja und das war ein Kunstwerk an
sich also ich finde ja schade sie waren
da ein bisschen spießig ehrlich gesagt
das ist doch lustig
machen
in der Pause dann versuchte mit sich mit
Hilfe Interesse Dame vom Hundekot im
Gesicht zu bekommen es gibt keine
schlechte Publicity und die ist jetzt
die bekannteste ballettkritikerin
Deutschlands und das Ihre nächste Kritik
egal was sie schreibt wird gelesen
werden irgendwas bleibt immer hängen
erwachsen ich hoffe ihnen passiert das
nicht
wenn sie mal einen Artikel schreiben der
nicht allen gefällt das passiert öfter
wenn wenn wir hoffentlich nicht in der
Bahn plötzlich erfahren Opfer einer
solchen Attacke also man muss ja schon
bei dem bleiben was rechtlich geboten
ist es wird ja auch in der Luft dieses
Jahr austeilen kann der muss auch
einstecken können das ist glaube ich das
Thema dass du jetzt auch so ein bisschen
tangiert hast müssen Journalisten aus
deiner Sicht einstecken können jetzt
abseits ist dieser Attacke ich glaube da
sind wir uns alle einig weit über der
Grenze war aber wo ist für dich die
ganze erstmal sagt ja das das muss ich
auch einstecken können wenn ich das
austeile also Patricia wir wissen das
beide wir arbeiten für eine Boulevard
Marke hier bei Bild und unser Job ist
eigentlich den mächtigen vorzuhalten was
die falsch machen wir sind wir werden
dafür bezahlt Leute zu kritisieren und
natürlich werden die Küche will muss
auch die Hitze aushalten können wenn wir
dann zurück aktiviert werden dann ist
das ganz normal ehrlich gesagt wäre es
wahrscheinlich sogar schlecht wenn es
nicht so wäre ob Kacke im Gesicht sein
muss klar kann man machen kann man
vielleicht auch lieber lassen aber ich
finde eigentlich dass wir da durchaus
auch in der Bringschuld sind ein dickes
Fell zu haben
und wenn dann mal einer kommt und ich
versuche zu beschmieren
also wir wollen nicht hoffen
keiner sich wünscht das so etwas
jemanden einem anderen wieder fährt